um
we were talking about lanny uh lainey
poffo who is randy savage uh
um macho man's uh brother and
um lanny has a story um that he tells
i think it's in the dark um you know
when first of all we went out
as far and wide as we could to find
any video we could even an early early
early promo
with randy's original voice his
real voice it was a pain in the ass but
i think we finally dug one up and it's
definitely a different voice and
what lanny says is that when randy
he was working on it it came to lanny
for advice he was working on his voice
his
you know part of his persona um to help
connect
and so uh
when he nailed it lanny says very mellow
dramatically he said
i knew after that moment
i never heard my brother's real voice
ever again
really ever again he was just
permanently
that character and that in that voice
and
and many people say that you know that
randy savage's life
outside the ring very much mirrored you
know
the drama uh in and around the ring you
know on camera let's say
he was you know he was a man perpetually
set to 11 on the dial you know just like
you know full steam ahead and and um we
interviewed dan soder for the
documentary who is hilarious
he's an actor degenerate wrestling fan
um and you know he has this great bit at
the
i wonder if it made the final cut
because it was a little
edgy you know he talks about how like
you know i'll be more sensitive about it
but he does it in a very
tasteful and funny way but it's edgy but
how like
the way randy went out was like the most
macho man randy savage way to go out it
was like his
final you know his final sort of
dramatic
moment and dan uses wrestling terms
which i'm not entirely familiar with but
you know it was a really interesting
point that for a man who lived
full throttle like this was like you
know
the most macho man way of like ending a
match you know or ending you know
or fading out um and it's not uh not
untrue
yeah when you're when you're revved up
to 11 like that
all the time i mean you got to be
burning the candle at both ends you're
not going to last that long
and i mean i think wrestling is is a
is a sport kind of i don't know if it's
unique to wrestling or what the what the
the comparative stats are to other
sports but it is a sport
that seems to have a pretty significant
number of
early deaths you know a um
pretty tragic miss elizabeth is one she
was 40 what was she like in her early to
mid 40s
um when she passed and like you see a
lot of
it's wrestling seems to have a lot of
those tragedies
what kind of drugs do you think randy
was on like during matches what kind of
[ __ ] do you think he took i mean he had
to be on some sort of [ __ ] speed or
cocaine or well i mean back in like the
90s
late 80s 90s drug trends are cyclical
so i think that they were into what
the population was into so i don't know
that
that randy did uh cocaine in the 80s but
he lived in florida in the 80s uh
and was making money and was partying
hard
and like you know um i think some of
those guys have been a little more
candid about their
you know about their drug use and abuse
but
you know certainly um
you know i i think it's it not
surprising to learn that that there were
steroids
you know uh uh uh involved you know
performance enhancement drugs
uh involved we get into that uh
later on in the dock again i haven't
seen the final cut so i don't know what
make
did or didn't make uh the cut after it
comes out
i'm happy to and i said if i watch it
i'm happy to
tell you all the [ __ ] whether the
deleted scenes are or whatever but
you know in the 90s we interviewed
gorgeous george uh his ex-girlfriend
in the 90s who who he he dated pretty
steadily
after miss elizabeth um and
they live together um you know in in
tampa bay area
and um she tells us that um
randy's pouch belt always had ecstasy in
it
and they didn't make sense they did a
lot of in the 90s
now i don't uh they did a lot of rolling
and she said there was at least one
occasion
um on wcw i think we tried to get some
footage where they were rolling on air
like like um for sure and they had some
pretty wild experiences like
they would go out on the beach in saint
pete
and and uh and do
uh ecstasy and i'm like it's gotta be a
thousand degrees you know if you're
you know like first of all you're out in
the florida sun and second you're doing
ecstasy or by and she goes yeah we got
really warm
and we went out into the water and there
was these guys on the water
who were screaming and yelling and
waving at us and we were screaming and
yelling
and waving back and then randy got
pissed
because he randy thought these guys were
like flirting
with uh with gorgeous george and he got
he was always very jealous and so
he finally said well [ __ ] this and he
storms out of the water and it's like
what the [ __ ] are you guys trying to
like
get my girl's attention which is
ridiculous because he's out there with
them you know but he was sometimes
irrational
and he was rolling let's be you know
real so and they're like no
dude there was a school of sharks that's
why we all came
out of the water and they were trying to
get their attention to get the [ __ ] out
of the water
because they were swimming in a school
of like of sharks yeah
what we were talking about with the hulk
and randy beef where kind of like
it all spills outside the ring and the
line starts to blur
between the kind of persona and
entertainment versus real life or you
know like
how does this how to sort of like tweef
to
you know twitter beef how does tweef
kind of like spill out
into litigation like i mean i don't know
listen it's the reason why you and i
still have jobs
the reason why there's there's podcasts
you know there's a lot of [ __ ] to talk
about there's a lot of [ __ ] to make to
make documentaries about you know
yeah well i try to stay away from like
the interpersonal drama on social media
between people
i i'd stay away from that like the
plague but
i don't know it's interesting that you
bring up like someone's
in you know their internet persona or
who they are online kind of like
spilling over to real life is
exactly what we're talking about with
wwe wwe and randy and hulk
it reminds me of skip bayless on
undisputed
how he's like the guy who hates lebron
like that dude is
such a [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] the way he
talks about lebron he's such a dick
and it's so [ __ ]
biased like no matter what it is he's
just playing i feel like he's playing
this character
of like the guy who hates lebron and
props up everybody else who competes
against lebron and i i personally think
that it could have been
something that he maybe did when he was
on espn and it worked and then he just
leaned into it and then it just sort of
like bled into his real life and maybe
it's now
maybe that's who he really is now
i